so what challenges did you find dating
in new york i've heard terrible things
why is new york so much worse than the
rest of the country
um i think it's not necessarily just new
york i think it's any one of the major
cities so for sure i would say new york
and la probably have similar issues the
main issue that i've noticed from dating
in new york is there's just way too many
options that's i think the problem
number one the other major issue i
noticed is people move to new york if
they don't live here people move to new
york because they move here for their
career so people are very
career focused so that becomes the
priority and then they kind of put
dating on the back burner so
people might be going on dates but
they're like i'm too busy i don't have
time like i don't they don't want to put
in the time to date because they're
laser focused but i'm like you go out
and hang out with your friends
you have a social life you could also do
the same thing for dating but i think
people just kind of use it as an excuse
but you know i love that about new york
that people are so driven but that's a
hard part is people are really focused
on their career
and most people don't really settle down
in new york until they're in their 30s
or 40s which is unlike other places i
grew up in florida
almost all my friends are like married
with kids on multiple kids and they were
kind of settling down in their mid-20s
and if you don't live in a place like
new york people don't quite understand
how you could be in your 30s and still
very single
and if you live here you understand
you're like oh
people are just career focused but yeah
most people don't think about it till
they're in their 30s or 40s which just
makes dating a little bit harder if
you're someone who's like late 20s and
you're like i know i'm ready for
something but no one else is so then
you're kind of sifting through the pool
hoping you find someone who's also ready
to settle down with you
did you so when did you move to new york
i moved to york in 2012 so i just
celebrated nine years in new york
okay so how old would that would be
when i moved to new york i was 26.
exactly i'll be
i'll be 36 this year so i was like 26
going on 27 when i moved to new york
okay so it was like you were kind of in
a place where you moved to new york
where you were ready to settle down and
you just felt like the dating pool
wasn't
um i thought i was ready to settle down
looking back
i thought
then that i was ready for a relationship
um i've been single for a lot chunk of
my life i was a late bloomer in life i
didn't have my first boyfriend so i was
26. that was right before i moved to new
york i worked in a cruise ship and we
broke up because it was long distance
and we didn't want to do it so i moved
to new york and i knew that i really
enjoyed being in a relationship even
though it was short term i still enjoyed
that so i was like you know i'm i feel
like i'm ready to meet my my person so i
kind of put myself out there but looking
back now i wasn't the best version of me
for that relationship and i didn't know
it at the time so i was just you know
going on dates you know really actively
trying to meet someone and just
not having any luck so it was just
a lot of frustration
and when you say like the you weren't
the best version of you like what were
there mistakes that you made like why do
you say that yeah so um i think the main
things i realized is i think
my mindset wasn't in the right place i
think because i was a late bloomer in
life like i didn't really date till i
was in my mid-20s and having been single
for most of my life i had a mindset of
like i'm going to be single forever i'm
never going to meet anyone and whether
we believe it or not those kind of
thoughts do mirror your reality around
you so
even though i knew i wanted to be in a
relationship deep down i secretly
thought i'm never gonna find someone
like i'm gonna be alone forever so
that kind of cared with me a lot in my
dating and i didn't know it at the time
until i started going to therapy and
realizing a lot of these things about
myself so i think that was it also i
think i was just i was so hung up on
like every date i went on so many dates
being like is this the last first date
i'm going on and that should never be
that should never be your michael coming
in but at the time
i don't know i didn't really know a lot
of things i was naive i was still new to
dating um so i didn't know a lot of
these things but i just went in with a
completely wrong mindset
um and i've always been a pretty
positive person most of my life but i
realized it wasn't always coming from an
authentic place
and so i had to learn to truly just be
happy with myself
single or not whether i meet a partner
in life or not like before i met my
boyfriend it's like i have a great life
i've created a great life if i never
find a partner like i still have an
amazing life but i didn't quite have
that mindset when i first moved to new
york it's like i've built this life for
myself but deep down i always was like
had that like worry or that pit and you
really have to learn to be happy by
yourself no matter what because if
you're dwelling on the fact that i'm
alone and nobody wants me like it's just
not good energy to carry around
so yeah that was definitely one of the
mistakes i made i just approached dating
all wrong it's not a good way to
appreciate it well we even talked about
how um were you part of the like men or
trash um you know camp at all during
this time
no i don't think i ever really
okay off men were trash per se and i
know what you're talking about because
there's a lot of women who fully are
like man-hating and i'm like
how do you like you like how do you
expect to find a man if you're fully
like hating them so i was never really
on the men are trash it was just so much
frustration with not meeting good men
so then i guess i guess in a way i guess
i lied i guess in a way there were parts
of me that were like ah there's no good
men left out there but i wasn't
necessarily screaming like i hate men
men or trash
like
are there still good men out there and i
think that's a little bit different than
like men or trash yeah i think i think
there's a fine line it can kind of cross
over a little bit but it definitely
wasn't like i hate men men are stuck
like there's no need for that i
definitely was not on that being wagon
but i definitely for a while thought to
myself like there's no good men left
like how where are people meeting their
partners like there's no good men left
and you you kind of have to get out of
that because
it will follow you like that
carries with you well that's like one of
the biggest mistakes i think i see women
making dating where they're just like
really frustrated
um and they'll just we'll just say like
things that are so rude like towards men
like men are trash like they're the
problem like
i hate men whatever and i'm just like
that we would not accept that if they
said that about women you know
exactly and i see so many tick tocks
have like so much negative energy around
dating which is why like once i started
realizing what worked for me and my this
might not work for everyone but i've
tried a lot of the other things which is
why i think some of the things that i
did are better ways to go about it but i
see so much negative tick tocks and
that's why now my focus is to help other
people
find that you know amazing partner or
like at least give them tips to be like
hey you can find what you want you just
gotta have to stay open and be positive
and like i know it's frustrating but
like don't my thing is like don't give
up because your person's out there and
some people meet their person later in
life and some people meet them early in
life
but i feel like there is someone out
there for everyone i know people don't
always believe that but i do believe
there's someone out there for everyone
if that's what you want so i'm like now
trying to help people
not make mistakes i made because i feel
like that set me back a lot but you know
you learn from everything and
this is part of my journey and i have no
regrets no matter what
well it's interesting i actually i
disagree with something you said
so i don't think there's a person for
everyone i think there's a person for
everyone if you make the correct life
choices uh okay yeah so you know what i
mean so like for example um like one
thing that i don't think like as women
we're really like honest about with each
other sometimes it's like if you gain a
lot of weight less guys are going to be
interested you know that i mean it's
part of life i don't like it you know
right it is but
right and it's like
i think that the choices we make like
dictate the type of partner we get
rather than like having one person like
out there for everyone so like for
example if you want a fit partner like
you have to be in shape yourself you
know
or um if you want like a friendly
partner you have to be friendly yourself
like i really think like we get what we
put out in the world
yeah i will i will agree with you in
that in some sense i do say
like i agree with your statement of like
there's not there might not be someone
out there for you based on like how you
change what i do say is i believe that
there are always going to people be
people who like you
as you are it may not be the people
you're attracted to that's what i feel
so like i do that there's always going
to be someone who finds you attractive
and like wants to be with you but if
you're someone like first that's like
unhappy with your body or things like
that
the partner the partners that you want
may not be the people that you want so
if that makes sense so i feel like
there's always gonna be something for
you that it might not be the person that
you want for yourself and i think that's
where people have to understand like for
instance i live a fit and active
lifestyle i don't necessarily need a
partner who's like at the gym set like i
don't need a sick i don't need to be
with a partner who's a six pack abs and
all that some people that's important to
them so yeah they're probably
surrounding themselves at like crossfit
or the gym
for other people you'll see partners
where one person's really fit and one
person's not as fit but they may still
do active things together so
i think also understanding like what is
important for you it's not always
important for the other person but you
do have to understand that there will
always be someone that likes you but it
may not be the people that you have and
that's what you
have to understand so i agree
that's actually really true there's
because as girls that's so true there is
always someone that likes you as as a
girl i think not all guys right as a
girl and it's but it's not always going
to be the person you like back and you
have to understand if there's something
you don't like about yourself you have
the power to change it don't just sit in
this woe as me
and you have to want to do it for
yourself that's the key you can't want
to do it to retract a partner you can't
want to do it for some other reason you
have to do it for yourself because then
it's never going to stick and then when
you start making changes with yourself
and you're happy then you know like you
said the things around you will start to
mirror that
yeah no that's that's so true um
okay so you said what you were looking
for in a partner
have you always been looking for the
same thing in a partner or did that
change over time
i feel like that changed over time um
i i don't i don't think i was specific
enough in what i was looking for a
partner when i first started dating in
new york i just knew like i want a
boyfriend i want to be in a relationship
i'm going to go on dates and like hope
to meet my person
and so i was just kind of going on dates
and like you know for me i was someone
who like had their glow up later in life
like i feel like i look at pictures of
myself in high school or like early
college and i'm like
just you know but that's that's my story
so for
when i started getting attention from
guys when i had my glow up i never
really had that kind of attention before
so when i first started dating i kind of
was going for ego to be like
these are people i was attracted to when
i was younger who never gave me the time
of day and now i'm getting it like i
know that that's part of what it was
early on as i was kind of like trying to
boost my ego a little bit which is
always the best way to go about dating
and i have no regrets about that it is
nice to have an ego boosting like wow
this person is like hot like i've been
out with some people that i'm like
like okay you know did you what do you
mean a glow up did you like lose a lot
of weight or something no because you're
you're like clearly in great shape like
yeah that's right in your arms i'm in
great shape now like i work out now i
live in an active lifestyle now but i
wasn't always that way i was like a band
geek in high school i was a nerd i was a
little bit heavier i was never like fat
per se like if you looked at me like i'm
curvy so i've always had a big butt like
it's just small smaller now that i've
like gotten in shape but you know it's a
little you know a little extra meat on
my bones but i was never like
obese or fat or anything like that you
know why you if you look at pictures of
me even from
10 years ago you can see my face is a
little bit rounder you can see the
difference between the two but i decided
to adopt a healthy lifestyle once i
graduated college and i wanted to do it
for me because it's like i was eating a
lot of fast food i just wasn't eating
the healthiest and then i started
pursuing acting and i also you know high
blood pressure runs in my family
diabetes runs in my family so part of it
was for health reasons i didn't want to
have to worry about those things um and
then i started taking care of myself and
it's like oh i feel better and i look
better and i like
living an active lifestyle
but let's be honest if i was always 100
pounds growing up i probably wouldn't
give a crap about what i ate you know
like
but i'm glad that i do have to live an
active lifestyle so i'm not just eating
crap all the time because i like i
splurge a good like in moderation but
even sometimes when i explore just like
i just feel
gross because you know when you're not
used to eating that stuff but i now take
good care of myself just because it's
something i try like it i like it for
myself but uh i wasn't necessarily like
an ugly duckling per se but i just feel
like you can look at old photos of me
and you're like okay
um
wait so
you said your type so at first you were
chasing more of like the good looking
guys and then it switched so i've always
so she i was kind of chasing good
looking guys but i don't you know i like
nerdy guys too like i i feel like i tell
people i was like you gotta go for like
the super cute nerd because they're like
they're they don't have a crazy ego
they're also very nice people and like
everyone needs love too so i feel like
yes it's nice to like have the really
hot arm candy but it's not about at the
end of the day i learned it's not always
about looks i feel like people think
it's about looks and like you have to be
the most beautiful woman on the planet
and you have to be for guys maybe they
think like oh girls you need to have a
six-pack it's not about that like yes
you want to feel good about yourself and
take care of yourself but it's really
like who are you as a person like how do
you carry yourself and are you meeting
someone who like matches that energy and
has those same goals
so i think
you know i do kind of have it
my friends are like you like to date men
who walk at it look like they walked out
of a banana republic catalog and i was
like you're not wrong
but so i do like have a type per se but
even with that
it's like i really just want to have a
good time with the person and like enjoy
their company generally enjoy their
company but i wasn't specific in what i
wanted for a partner until about two
years ago
um when i
heard someone say like sit down and
write down
all of the qualities you want in a
partner like what are your core values
like you want because that's really what
matters at the end of the day so i sat
down and i wrote a list of like all the
things i wanted a partner like i want
someone who's super supportive of me and
my career who's very caring who's honest
is loyal
you know you can you know some women
even get even as specific as like he has
to be
i don't think you need to go specific
where it's like he has to be five six
and taller like for me it's like that
didn't really matter it's more about
what are the core values that i'm
looking for in a person but i wrote down
like two pages of all the things i truly
wanted i folded it up i put it in an
envelope and i forgot about it i kind of
was like okay the universe knows what i
want i'm just gonna kind of take steps
towards these goals and trust that this
person will show up um so that was one
of the things i did and then i also like
went to therapy just so i could
be the you know work through some things
i think everyone has their own
background trauma they have to work
through and i think that's so important
when you are trying to build up a life
with someone that it's important that
you work out that stuff before you get
in
except so you're not bringing all of
that with you
i actually didn't even know that you
went to therapy like that's great i
think therapy is awesome therapy is
amazing i think every single person
should be in therapy whether you've gone
through anything traumatic or not i
think it's just a really good safe space
to talk about life and your feelings but
i still feel like there's this stigma
around therapy not so much anymore i
feel like we're moving in the direction
where it's become more normal but for
years it's almost like if you told
someone you were in therapy they're like
what's wrong with you it's like
therapy is a good it's mental health is
important like mental health matters and
so i'm glad people are moving in the
direction but yeah i went to therapy for
about two years so i think that was from
like 2016 to 2018. i went to therapy and
i had a really great therapist she was
wonderful i loved her a lot
um you know what's so crazy thing i
don't think men are as picky as we think
like
really really like i've been watching
like men's dating content for months and
all they want is someone in better shape
than them whatever they're at just
better shape than them right like
feminine right and friendly like that's
literally it that's like the three and
supportive and a good person i think you
just yeah they're a good person with
good intentions yeah like there's a lot
of guys that are sick of being used for
their money right because these girls
will use them for like a date with no
intention of ever dating them yeah i
feel like i watched um i don't remember
where i watched this video but i watched
it a couple years ago and there was a
woman who clearly said oh yeah i go out
on dates like
four day like four days a week just to
get free dinner and it boggles my mind
that women are in this gold digger
mindset i'm like why though like you
should don't you have money to take
yourself out to dinner why do you need
to use someone
just to go out together and that's
different than like dating multiple
people with intention and then you may
happen to go on a few days a week but
there are some women who fully just go
on dates because they want men to pay
for them and i'm like yeah that energy
comes back to haunt you i'm a believer
in that and that's another thing like i
think a lot of like trauma on both ends
would be avoided if we all just dated
intentionally yes like because i think a
lot of times girls kind of wait around
and like hope for something more than
like they're really gonna get you know
and even though like girl's going to be
like oh he didn't tell me but 90 of the
time guys tell us we don't listen you
know what i mean we we hope and like
hope for the best and hope they can
change but like
i think that like dating intentionally
is super important
yes and that's where i started seeing
the shift
was when i started dating intentionally
i don't know how long you've been seeing
my videos but i don't know if you saw
the video i made in december of last
year of me fully crying on tick tock and
i was like i don't even know why i'm
crying this is so dumb i just been
ghosted by a guy and i like was over it
because i felt like i kept getting
ghosted and which ghosting is a cop out
don't ghost be upfront with your
feelings like we're all adults stop
ghosting that's my yes
but i made a video where i was just
really upset and over it and i was like
you know are there any good people left
and i decided to take a break after that
and like take a break and come and i
took a few months off and came back
refreshed and i started dating more
intentionally meaning like and i
primarily use the dating apps just
because i live in new york city it's
busy also there's a pandemic we can't
meet at the bar like we used to there's
not as many events but once i started
dating more intentionally i started
paying more attention to who i was
swiping on i adjusted my profile so that
if someone looked i wanted it to be so
if someone looked at my profile they
could say like oh wow this person really
looks like they're looking for something
and i want them to be like she looks fun
i want to meet her and i ended up
getting like in all of the people i
dated up until this point they all said
you had such a great profile like i
looked at your photos and i was like you
look like you're someone who's really
fun to hang out with and i want to meet
and so i started just being more
intentional
and i think you have to be because there
are a lot of people who waste your time
and sadly you know people are just on
board and they're looking to stroke
their ego and then it sucks for people
who really do want to meet someone and
are putting themselves out there and
then when you're met with too many
people who are just wasting your time
then you say you know what's the point
and then you kind of give up and
do you wanna you wanna know a crazy stat
that i found out this is gonna blow your
mind um 20 of men have sexual access to
80 of women so the reason that girls
hate men is because like they're all
sleeping with the same ones
wait say that again so 20 of single men
have sexual access to 80 of women oh
geez wow so the reason that women like
feel this way about men a lot of times
like there's no good men left is because
we're all going after the same guys
oh
i'm so bad about that yeah so 80 of men
are not having sex with anyone
of single men single yeah obviously like
50.
wow
that's crazy
that's wild that's
crazy that's that's that blew my mind um
okay so
you you went to therapy you started
working on yourself mm-hmm what um
did you feel excited i have a question
for you sometimes i feel like girls at
first have like some superficial
requirements so like
right you know like height is first one
that comes to my eye but money whatever
um and sometimes i feel like a lot of
times they aren't realistic
do you feel like that's a problem that
you see was that ever a problem for you
or no
not really um
i'm the kind of person like i'm an
actress i live in new york city i'm not
making my full income from acting but so
i wait tables to pay my bills but i have
a make a good living but for me i'm
someone that i'm like i don't care what
kind of job you have like as long as you
can support yourself independently
outside of this relationship and you're
not relying on me
i don't care you could be flipping
burgers and if you're making enough
money to support yourself that's fine
but there are so many women that are
like if he doesn't make
per year
or this i won't give him the time of day
i'm like but why though there's so many
good men that like
they're they're financially i feel like
if they're financially stable which is
really all anyone's asking for like be
financially stable and please don't be
living with your parents and like
you don't have to live on your own
because i live in new york so it's
common for everyone to live with
roommates just because it's expensive
here so things like that don't bother me
hi for me on height the only thing for
me that i couldn't do
i'm five six i couldn't date someone
like i've dated a few people who have
five five but any shorter than that for
me i've tried i like went on a date with
a guy a couple years ago he was so nice
but he was 5'4 and i couldn't get over
the fact that he was so short and i was
like i felt like a terrible human being
so i'm like is this that i'm like listen
some people have what they have but for
me i'm like i don't care about
that per se i'm like as long as you're
at least my height or taller i'm like it
doesn't matter to me the only other
thing for me is like i do work out i
live a healthy lifestyle i could not be
with someone who
was like severely overweight because for
me like the things that i want to do i
just don't know if that person would be
able to get out with me
so for me those were the two main things
is like i don't need someone to be going
to the gym every day but i do help the
person i'm with like
does take care of their body and you
know maybe you work out two days a week
or something and you eat someone
splurge on dates for me that was
important for me but i don't need
someone to have a six-pack or things
like that but there are a lot of women
that focus so much on the superficial
aspect and that's not gonna make a
lasting relationship yes well that's